[Music]
stan
venus man botticelli no relation was
jolted out of his dreams of dancing
girls in endless buffets by a seismic
shock that threw him violently to the
floor of his tastefully appointed
bedroom
he immediately leaped to his feet clad
only in silk boxer shorts
flabby muscles tensed beneath his
leathery flesh looking left and right
for the author of this indignity
as he huffed air at his nose there came
another massive jolt that sent him
flying across the bed
scrabbling for purchase amid pricey
linen sheets
then the rumbling stopped and stan
rolled off the bed in one motion
grabbing the handheld two-way radio from
the nightstand into pressing the button
parker parker what the hell is going on
over there
there was a pause that seemed endless
but was really only 10 seconds or so
and then a thick woman's voice emerged
from the static why the hell are you
calling me at 6am stan
i'm calling you because there's a [ __ ]
another jolt knocked him off his feet
and he barked his shin painfully on the
edge of the bed frame
in the midst of his colorful string of
curses he barely noticed that he had
begun sliding toward the bedroom door
the radio in his hands squealed
then rachel parker's voice burst through
again stan what was that noise
stan tried to grab hold of something
anything but his grasping fingers
slipped uselessly off the furniture
he managed to get the radio up to his
lips earthquake he shrieked into it his
throat protesting such vigorous use
glass was breaking everywhere in the
house and he had to shield his head as
knickknacks came raining down from the
shelving
followed by the shelving itself he slid
freely on the hardwood why hadn't he put
carpet up here for christ's sake
and only stopped when he maneuvered
awkwardly and wedged his leg in the
doorway
bring the chopper he screamed at the
radio the whole place is falling apart
he used the door molding to leverage his
way to an unsteady standing position
and hurry up oh well yes sir parker said
dryly
then the radio went silent the tremor
stopped but stan wasn't letting that
fact fool him again
carefully he reached behind the door and
snagged his robe from the hook
he would have liked to be more
presentable but parker had certainly
seen him wearing less
besides he could get some proper clothes
when she got him back to the mainland
for now he just wanted to get the hell
out of here before the walls came
crashing down on him
from his vantage point to the top of the
staircase he could clearly see that the
entire downstairs was in shambles
paintings lying face down and torn
broken ceramic littering the floor
heavy chairs and tables jumbled against
the west wall black skid marks across
the marble telling of their abrupt
passage
stan swore some more then made himself
calm down
dropping the radio into the pocket of
his robe he began making his way toward
the stairs
hanging onto the wall with flattened
palms knees bent to absorb another jolt
all was well until he was halfway down
the steps and then a tremor many times
worse than the first two
shook the building to its foundations
stan was lifted off his feet and would
have gone careening off into space had
he not been holding the banister in a
death grip
the radio slipped out of his pocket and
shattered into a million pieces on the
tile below
ominous creeks had begun emitting from
the ceiling stan didn't look up
when the tremor passed stan steadied
himself on shaky legs and mentally
judging the distance
to the front door decided to make a run
for it
one more tremor like the last one and
the whole enchilada was coming down
right on top of him
and as much as his affection for rachel
had waned over the years
he still didn't like the thought of her
finding his broken carcass buried in a
towering heap of expensive rubble
he wasted a few precious seconds
breathing in and out trying to work up
his courage
then shut down his brain and let his
survival instinct take over
he ran his legs pumping leaping over
smashed vases and ruined art objects
he had nearly made it to the door when
the world began to shake again
this time the creaking of the masonry
had become a roar and stan felt
particles of dust landing on his head
and shoulders as he ran
a moment later there was a tremendous
crash right behind him
without turning to look stan assumed the
destruction of his prized crystal
chandelier
he reached the door and fumbled with the
lock praying to god and mary and the
baby jesus that this pile would hold out
for just a couple more seconds
and then the door was open and he was
outside the fishy salty smell of the air
like the sweetest perfume on earth
he tore across the circular driveway not
feeling the rough grade of the concrete
on his bare feet
and as the rumble deepened he threw
himself into the grass away from the
house
and from his prone position finally
turned his head like lot's wife to see
what was what
for a moment he thought his vision must
be skewed because the entire house was
leaning like a parallelogram like the
pisa monument
the glass had broken out of most of the
windows raining down like hail
and the chimney was dumping bricks down
into the flower beds
there was a suspended instant in which
all sound and motion ceased
and stan thought that he was still in
bed upstairs and that his pleasant
dancing girl's dream had taken a bizarre
turn
but then a deafening thunder pierced the
air coming from deep below the ground
and the house went down in a single
perfect arc just as though it was made
of nothing more substantial than playing
cards or balsa wood
the cloud of dust and debris that
followed was apocalyptic
seeming to blot out the sun choking stan
and its gray brown embrace
in the midst of this stifling darkness
dan realized he was sliding again
or more accurately tumbling off the
carefully cultivated patch of grass that
surrounded what was left of the house
he bumped along on the untended rocky
terrain of the island
seeing nothing but the occasional flash
of blue sky above him than below him
as he rolled ass over tit he thought he
might have been screaming but there was
too much noise and darkness and chaos
he could have been dead for all he knew
when quiet came it seemed very sudden
and stan wondered if he'd blacked out
and if he had for how long he was aware
that his throat felt raw and shredded
probably from screaming and coughing but
he also noticed that the air had cleared
somewhat allowing him to get a good look
at what had happened to his island
waving smoke away he assessed his
position the quake had thrown him nearly
to the waterline which seemed much
closer to the home site than it had been
previously
to stand the reason for this soon became
obvious the entire island looked to have
tilted about 30 degrees
stan was reluctant to stand up for fear
of a last devastating tremor that would
plunge him into the gulf
so he rolled himself into a hunching
stance tucking his knees beneath him
he glanced briefly over at the ruin not
really lamenting the wreckage of the
house
since he had others but more irritated
by the inconvenience and loss of dignity
the whole episode had caused
stan was used to being in control he
didn't like even mother nature thinking
she could pull one over on him
and where the hell was parker with that
chopper would she even be able to land
the thing
as he pondered these questions stan's
roving gays caught on something just at
the shoreline
furrowing his brow he duck walked over
for a closer look
something appeared to be wedged beneath
the lip of the island trapped on a sort
of ledge formed by the new tilt in the
land
the water was cloudy from the upheaval
and stan couldn't really make it out
it looked white and sort of shiny almost
like satin
whatever it was it also looked very big
stan had just leaned forward for a
better look when he heard the
unmistakable were of propeller blades
echoing across the waves
he turned to see the black silhouette of
parker's chopper superimposed against
the pink morning sky
forgetting the danger of further tremors
and momentarily forgetting the strange
white object in the water
stan stood upright and waved his arms to
greet the chopper
you're a complete idiot you know that
right stan looked up from fiddling with
his scuba mask
good thing you divorced me then isn't it
the chopper blades whacked above them as
parker guided the gleaming back machine
over the clear teal waters of the gulf
islands poked through the waves at odd
intervals beige sandy blots encircled by
white froth
stan still wasn't entirely sure what it
was that he'd seen near the shore after
the earthquake yesterday but he had a
hunch it might be something
interesting and following his hunches
was what had made him his ill-gotten
fortune
as well as kept him alive while he was
making it
the ground is probably unstable as hell
parker was shouting over the roar of the
engine
you're lucky i even got you off there
yesterday if this baby goes into the
gulf i'm taking every cent out of your
fat white ass
stan laughed parker had always been
abrasive but it was one of the things he
liked about her
besides he knew that deep down she was
just as curious about all this as he was
maybe more rachel set the chopper down a
little way from the ruin of the house
where the slope didn't seem quite so
severe without a word she then helped
stan
unload his scuba gear and set it down on
the beach once he had started to don the
tank and flippers she said
if you find anything momentous don't
forget who rushed here at the ass crack
of dawn when your house was falling down
she crossed her arms stan waddled over
to her and kissed her brow
i would never do such a thing you're
still my one and only
and it was true stan hadn't so much has
touched another woman since rachel had
left him three years ago
be careful down there she gave a wand
little smile
the most emotion she generally ever
showed stan nodded and gave her a jaunty
salute then flopped off toward the water
once below the surface stan had to
struggle to see much of anything
the water was still clouded with churned
silt from yesterday's cataclysm
a few small yellow fish darted past his
face before disappearing into the murk
stan hoped there were no sharks sneaking
up on him in the darkness
after a few moments he became more
accustomed to the blue green gloom and
was able to make out some vague shapes
he began to swim around what he hoped
was the shoreline of the island but
something seemed to miss
he had been diving around here for many
years even before he had built the house
and as far as he knew the island had
always traced a smooth
barnacle-encrusted slope all the way to
the sandy bottom of this fairly deep
part of the gulf
but now the way ahead of him seemed dark
and amorphous not at all like the solid
rock that should have been there
with a start he realized that a cave had
opened up right beneath the island
as soon as he'd internalized this fact
he began to see the curiously smooth rim
of the thing
hanging there in the dimness arching up
and back
well he'd have to go in there the
interesting thing he'd seen had surely
been forced up when the cave opened
maybe it was a large mineral deposit
unearthed after millions of years
or maybe some rare fossil of an unknown
species the possibilities made his skin
tingle
cautiously mindful that the whole thing
might collapse on him at any second
stan glided into the blackness
parker was certainly showing emotion
today she was standing on the deck of
the freighter her mouth hanging open
her eyes as big as saucers unbelievable
she breathed looking up at the thing
that is [ __ ]
unbelievable momentous enough for you my
dear
stan was pacing the deck barely able to
contain himself
the crew had spent the better part of
two days extracting his prize from the
wedge of newly yawning cave beneath the
gulf
and now that stan had seen it in its
entirety in its gigantic celestial glory
he was nearly exploding with happiness
there's nothing else like it in the
world he said
unable to stop himself from bouncing up
and down on the balls of his feet
it's priceless goddamn priceless and
will be famous parker
the botticelli parker pearl that has a
certain ring to it don't you think
i prefer the parker botticelli pearl
rachel said without taking her eyes off
it
the pearl that had been liberated by the
earthquake was nearly as big as stan's
ruined mansion had been
a perfect shimmering globe of color
shifting white its surface as smooth as
polished glass
it hung there like a captured planet its
beauty undiminished by the crisscrossing
of heavy rope netting that kept it
steady as the ship plowed its way toward
the mainland
news of the discovery had already begun
to circulate of course one couldn't hire
an extraction crew without there being
some rumors and leaks of information
stan had already got word that the
largest natural history museums in the
world were
engaging in a bidding war for the rights
to display the extraordinary find
stan would basically be able to take his
pick and name his price
the prospect of making boatloads of cash
naturally pleased him
but he was already a very wealthy man he
was infinitely more excited about the
renown the pearl would bring him
the attachment of his name and legacy to
something that was for all intents and
purposes
eternal hundreds of years from now
school children would listen and wonder
as museum curators described the brave
man who had risked his life
to find the largest most beautiful most
perfect pearl the world had ever seen
stan side he only wished his dear papa
was still alive to see it
the sun had begun to set across the prow
of the ship and the pearl took on the
lovely lavender orange hue of the sky
reflecting and scattering the colors
across its shining contours
stan moved closer to it his eyes
brimming with joyful tears
he stared at it adored it and reached
through the ropes to caress its satin
skin
that was still as cold as the water at
the bottom of the gulf
as the light grew dim he fancied he
could see the mirror image of his jowly
middle-aged face
looking back at him through gauzy layers
of opalescence
and then just before night fell
completely he thought he saw something
else
the vegas shadow within the pale globe a
shadow that seemed for the briefest
moment
to take the shape of a man stan
emptied a bottle of jack daniels into
one of the plastic cups from the minibar
and then knocked it back in one slug he
wished that parker had taken him up on
his offer to stay with him in the hotel
tonight but she had respectfully
declined
heading back to her apartment after
sharing one celebratory drink with him
stan thought he'd be upset but he found
that he wasn't maybe parker would come
around and maybe she wouldn't
he had the pearl and as of now that was
all he really needed
his prize and it would be the botticelli
parker pearl that much he had decided
was currently residing in a storage
hangar less than a block away from where
he was now sitting
even though he and the crew had covered
the treasure with yards of opaque
sheeting before coming into port
there had still been a large crowd of
curious onlookers on the shore to meet
them
stan was initially worried about all the
attention worried to let the pearl out
of his sight for a single instant
but as it was carefully loaded onto a
flatbed truck he was able to convince
himself he was overreacting
after all who would be able to steal a
pearl as big as a couple of jumbo jets
pleasantly mellow stan went to the
window of his hotel room and looked out
into the night
he could just make out the curve of the
shoreline peppered with lights from
docks and boathouses
he glanced to his left and saw the
reassuring concrete and steel mass of
the building that housed his ticket to
immortality
the yellow moon hung over everything
like a sister gem shining in solidarity
he wasn't sure how long he was standing
there feeling the warm after-effects of
the alcohol seeping into his veins
before he realized he was hearing a
strange sound he tilted his head toward
the glass
trying to determine the source but
before he could he had a visual to
supplement the audio
the waves of the gulf were churning
madly toward the shore
pounding at the beach with sudden
awesome force at first stan simply
frowned
perhaps there was a storm whipping up
over the water although the forecast
hadn't predicted one
and it was too early in the season for a
hurricane more likely stan thought in
light of his mansion's destruction this
was yet another aftershock from that
fateful earthquake
now four days behind him could there be
a tremor after four days
stan wasn't sure the waves were coming
in earnest now huge swells that lapped
over the wooden decks and boat halls
along the beach
sending ropey white spray spattering the
clapboard walls of the fishing shacks
that line the dunes
stan's frown deepened he glanced up at
the sky but the night was clear
stars glittering hard against the
blackness no haze or squall line visible
for miles
the earthquake theory was beginning to
look like the more likely scenario
what if there was a tsunami stan had a
vivid mental picture of his doll-like
body being dragged into the depths of
the gulf
along with the round shimmering mass of
his pearl returning to its home beneath
the waves
stan decided he should turn on the tv
see if there was any evacuation warnings
or other news about what the hell was
going on
before he could turn from the window he
noticed something else
by the cold yellow light of the moon he
swore he could see a massive dark shape
in the water
moving toward the shore he closed his
eyes then opened them again
the numbing effect of the whiskey
dissolving in an instant
there was something something huge and
modeled moving in a bizarre
intermittent fashion seeming to shoot
forward quickly
stop then move forward again displacing
enormous quantities of water before its
dome-like bulk
initially stan thought this must be his
imagined tsunami but he had to admit
he'd never seen a wave move like that
jerky is a badly driven stick shift
without taking his eyes off the thing he
fished in his pocket for his cell phone
dialing parker's number from memory she
answered on the third ring
sounding a little drunk yeah parker you
can see the gulf from your apartment
window can't you
there was a pause why she said don't ask
stupid questions
the thing was closer now and stan
thought he could make out a surface that
appeared to be jagged grayish stone
look i'm not sure what it is but i think
there's some bad [ __ ] going down
just get in your car and start driving
inland okay i'm gonna head out soon too
i'll meet you he tried to think while
the thing was growing larger and larger
in his field of vision
at that denny's right there at the 19
junction got that
stan what the hell just do it the thing
loomed massive now under the moonlight
its preceding waves smashing into the
sands
lights had started to come on in some of
the houses and shadowed people milled
around on decks and balconies clearly
panicked
a child's shriek of terror penetrated
the night all right stan i'm going
parker grumbled but i still wish you'd
look out your damn window if you want to
know why he shouted and hung up
more screams were ringing in the streets
below and he started hearing doors
slamming in the babble of voices in the
hall outside his room
the thing was probably less than a half
a mile offshore now plowing up foam
before it
stan was poised to run but he was
momentarily transfixed by the sheer size
of the thing
and by its unnerving solidity jesus the
thing was easily the size of an island
stan's whiskey thinned blood turned to
ice in his veins
now that the thing was close he realized
that its contours were a little too
familiar
the color and texture of its leading
edge as known to him as the peaks and
valleys of his own flesh
with horror he recognized a shifting
pile of debris on the thing's surface
as the fallen bricks and twisted wooden
frame of the mansion he had once called
home
my island is coming to get me the idea
was so ridiculous that he laughed out
loud
even as people screamed in the streets
streaming out of their beach houses
toward higher ground
he found that he couldn't stop laughing
what the [ __ ] kind of earthquake is this
anyway
that question made him laugh even harder
then he remembered his pearl and the
laughter dried up in his throat
he wasn't losing that pearl vengeful
island or now
feet were pounding on the carpet out in
the hall and someone hammered at his
door with closed fists yelling for him
to get out
stan stood motionless for a moment more
watching the attacking hump of land
closing in on the shoreline like the
kraken
and then he leaped into action grabbing
a coat from the bedspread and throwing
it on over his rumpled suit
patting his pockets for keys and phone
he opened his door and slid into the
crowd of straggling escapees
most bleary-eyed and frightened a few in
their pajamas
stan threaded his way through them
anxious but purposeful
he was going to meet parker by the
highway soon enough but he was going to
check on that pearl first
if he couldn't find enough of the
security guys around to help him load it
back onto the truck then he would just
have to improvise
he might have to break into the hangar
and roll the [ __ ] all the way to us 19
but that was okay
he was certainly not leaving in here to
be washed back out to sea never to be
found again
the hotel parking lot was almost empty
as he crossed it only a few slow movers
starting their cars and peeling out
toward the east
stan broke into a jog keeping one eye on
the great looming hulk as he made his
way to the storage hangar
the water hadn't quite come up this far
yet but he could see that it wouldn't be
long before his feet got wet if not the
rest of him
the sentries at the hangar had
presumably abandoned their posts
stan swore at their cowardice how is he
going to get the pearl out now
he looked around in vain for something
to break the lock on the massive sliding
doors
finally he ducked into the guard shack
hoping that in the haste of evacuation
someone had left a set of keys behind
he was just reaching for a promising set
when the moon was blotted out
stan's heart stopped for a second then
tripped back into a rapid rhythm
he peered up through the dusty windows
the thing out there
the thing he'd been living on top of for
three years wasn't an island at all
its mouth was open an impossibly huge
half circle against the sky
the moon behind it giving its edges a
blazing white corona
the inside of its upper shell shimmered
even in the darkness
with beautiful shifting colors pink and
blue and violet
as iridescent as metal as the hues of a
butterfly's wings
the froth around its lower shell
surrounded it like a snowy beard
stan's brain completely shut down unable
to process what it was seeing
he stood there his mouth slack his hand
hanging in midair
reaching for a set of keys that he would
never get the chance to use
the thing had pushed its enormous bulk
part way under the shore
using muscles at its base to propel jets
of water out behind it
several of the houses along the shore
were crushed to tinder but there was no
one inside them now
the beach was deserted except for stan
and the agent of his reckoning
stan botticelli known as the venus man
by his associates and enemies
had a moment to admire the rosy
quivering flesh inside the thing's mouth
the soft bed where the pearl had grown
to its exquisite adulthood
and then the darkness descended the next
morning the sun crept up slowly
as if reluctant to shed light on the
consequences of the night's events
buildings roads and cars were smashed
flat in an oddly and almost perfectly
circular pattern that extended outward
for several miles
everything was wet the roads along the
shore were strewn with dead fish and
green ropes of seaweed
the hangar that had briefly housed the
most extraordinary find of the young
century
was reduced to a pile of twisted steel
and broken concrete
no trace of the pearl was ever
discovered even by those who bothered to
look
rachel parker who instead of heading
inland as she'd been told had driven to
stan's hotel to talk some sense into him
was reported missing by her mother a few
days after the incident
beneath the newly calm waters of the
gulf the upper and lower shells of the
leviathan came together with a
satisfying snap
the arch of its back once again forming
a round tranquil island
with gentle barnacle encrusted slopes
and inside the shell botticelli and
parker lay curled together as if
sleeping
surrounded by sand and wood splinters
and shattered glass and broken car parts
their bodies rested on the pink fleshy
bed that lined the lower
shell their intertwined flesh serving as
the shadowy catalyst
waiting through the long years as layer
after gauzy layer
it became part of the beauty of the
natural world and thus achieved a sort
of immortality
just biding the time beneath the waves
waiting for discovery
until the extraordinary affair at
sidmuth the peculiar species haplituthis
ferox
was known to science only generically on
the strength of a half-digested tentacle
obtained near the azores and a decaying
body packed by birds and nibbled by
fish found early in 1896 by mr jennings
near land's end
in no department of zoological science
indeed are we quite so much in the dark
as with regard to the deep sea
cephalopods
a mere accident for instance it was that
led to the prince of monaco's discovery
of nearly a dozen new forms in the
summer of 1895
a discovery in which the before
mentioned tentacle was included
it chanted that a cachalot was killed
after sierra
by some sperm whalers and in its last
struggles charged almost to the prince's
yacht
missed it rolled under and died within
20 yards of his rudder
and in its agony it threw up a number of
large objects which the prince
dimly perceiving they were strange and
important was by a happy expedient
able to secure before they sank he set
his screws in motion
and kept them circling in the vortices
thus created until a boat could be
lowered
and these specimens were whole
cephalopods and fragments of cephalopods
some of gigantic proportions and almost
all of them
unknown to science it would seem indeed
that these large and agile creatures
living in the middle depths of the sea
must to a large extent forever remain
unknown to us
since underwater they are too nimble for
nets and it is only by such rare
unlooked for accidents that specimens
can be obtained
in the case of haplituthis ferox for
instance we are still
altogether ignorant of its habitat as
ignorant as we are of the breeding
ground of the herring
or the seaways of the salmon and
zoologists are all together at a loss to
account for its sudden appearance on our
coast
possibly it was the stress of a hunger
migration that drove it hither out of
the deep
but it will be perhaps better to avoid
necessarily inconclusive discussion
and to proceed at once with our
narrative
the first human being to set eyes upon a
living haplotuthis
the first human being to survive that is
for there can be little doubt now
that the wave of bathing fatalities and
boating accidents
that traveled along the coast of
cornwall and devon in early may
was due to this cause was a retired tea
dealer by the name of feisen
who was stopping at a sidmuth boarding
house
it was in the afternoon and he was
walking along the cliff path between
sidmuth and ladram bay
the cliffs in this direction are very
high but down the red face of them
in one place a kind of ladder staircase
has been made
he was near this when his attention was
attracted by what at first he thought to
be a cluster of birds
struggling over a fragment of food that
caught the sunlight and glistened
pinkish white
the tide was right out and this object
was not only far below him
but remote across a broad waste of rock
reefs covered with dark seaweed
and interspersed with silvery shining
tidal pools
and he was moreover dazzled by the
brightness of the further water
in a minute regarding this again he
perceived that his judgment was at fault
forever this struggle circled a number
of birds jackdaws and gulls for
the most part the latter gleaming
blindingly when the sunlight smote their
wings
and they seemed minute in comparison
with it and his curiosity was
perhaps aroused all the more strongly
because of his first
insufficient explanations as he had
nothing better to do than amuse himself
he decided to make this
object whatever it was the goal of his
afternoon walk
instead of ladram bay conceiving it
might perhaps be a great fish of some
sort
stranded by some chance and flapping
about in its distress
and so he hurried down the long steep
ladder stopping at intervals of 30 feet
or so
to take breath and scan the mysterious
movement
at the foot of the cliff he was of
course nearer his object than he had
been
but on the other hand it now came up
against the incandescent sky
beneath the sun so as to seem dark and
indistinct
whatever was pinkish of it was now
hidden by a scary of weedy boulders
but he perceived that it was made up of
seven rounded bodies distinct or
connected
and that the birds kept up a constant
croaking and screaming
but seemed afraid to approach it too
closely
mr feison torn by curiosity began
picking his way across the wave-worn
rocks
and finding the wet seaweed that covered
them thickly rendered them extremely
slippery
he stopped removed his shoes and socks
and rolled his trousers above his knees
his object was of course merely to avoid
stumbling into the rocky pools about him
and perhaps he was rather glad as all
men are of an excuse to resume
even for a moment the sensations of his
boyhood
at any rate it is to this no doubt that
he owes his life
he approached his mark with all the
assurance which the absolute security of
this country against all forms of animal
life
gives its inhabitants the round bodies
moved to and fro
but it was only when he surmounted the
scary of boulders i have mentioned
that he realized the horrible nature of
the discovery
it came upon him with some suddenness
the rounded bodies fell apart as he came
into sight over the ridge
and displayed the pinkish object to be
the partially devoured body
of a human being but whether of a man or
woman he was unable to say
and the rounded bodies were new and
ghastly looking creatures
in shape somewhat resembling an octopus
with huge and very long and flexible
tentacles
coiled copiously on the ground the skin
had a glistening texture
unpleasant to see like shiny leather
the downward bend of the tentacle
surrounded mouth the curious excrescence
at the bend the
tentacles and the large intelligent eyes
gave the creatures a grotesque
suggestion of a face
they were the size of a fair-sized swine
about the body
and the tentacles seemed to him to be
many feet in length
there were he thinks seven or eight at
least of the creatures
twenty yards beyond them amid the surf
of the now returning tide
two others were emerging from the sea
their bodies lay flatly on the rocks and
their eyes regarded him with evil
interest
but it does not appear that mr faison
was afraid or that he realized that he
was in any danger
possibly his confidence is to be
ascribed to the limpness of their
attitudes
but he was horrified of course and
intensely excited and indignant
at such revolting creatures preying upon
human flesh
he thought they had chanced upon a
drowned body
he shouted to them with the idea of
driving them off and finding they did
not budge
cast about him picked up a big rounded
lump of rock and flung it at one
and then slowly uncoiling their
tentacles they all began moving towards
him
creeping at first deliberately and
making a soft purring sound to each
other
in a moment mr faison realized that he
was in danger
he shouted again through both his boots
and started off with a leap forthwith
20 yards off he stopped and faced about
judging them slow
and behold the tentacles of their leader
were already pouring over the rocky
ridge on which he had just been standing
at that he shouted again but this time
not threatening but a cry of dismay
and began jumping striding slipping
wading across the uneven expanse between
him and the beach
the tall red cliff seemed suddenly at a
vast distance
and he saw as though they were creatures
in another world two minute workmen
engaged in the repair of the latter way
and little suspecting the race for life
that was beginning below them
at one time he could hear the creature
splashing in the pools not a dozen feet
behind him
and once he slipped and almost fell they
chased him to the very foot of the
cliffs
and desisted only when he had been
joined by the workmen at the foot of the
latter way up the cliff
all three of the men pelted them with
stones for a time and then hurried to
the cliff top
and along the path towards sidmuth to
secure assistance in a boat
and to rescue the desecrated body from
the clutches of these abominable
creatures
and as if he had not already been in
sufficient peril that day
mr feisen went with the boat to point
out the exact spot of his adventure
as the tide was down it required a
considerable detour to reach the spot
and when at last they came off the
ladder way the mangled body had
disappeared
the water was now running in submerging
first one slab of slimy rock and then
another
and the four men in the boat the workmen
that is the boatman and mr feison
now turned their attention from the
bearings offshore to the water beneath
the keel
at first they could see little below
them save a dark jungle of laminaria
with an occasional darting fish their
minds were set on adventure
and they expressed their disappointment
freely but presently they saw one of the
monsters
swimming through the water seaward with
a curious rolling motion
that suggested to mr feisen the spinning
roll of a captive balloon
almost immediately after the waving
streamers of laminaria were
extraordinarily perturbed
parted for a moment and three of these
beasts became darkly visible
struggling for what was probably some
fragment of the drowned man
in a moment the copious olive green
ribbons had poured again
over this writhing group at that all
four men
greatly excited began beating the water
with oars and shouting
and immediately they saw a tumultuous
movement among the weeds
they desisted to see more clearly and as
soon as the water was smooth
they saw as it seemed to them the whole
sea bottom among the weeds
set with eyes ugly swine
cried one of the men why there's dozens
and forthwith the things begin to rise
through the water about them
mr feisen has since described to the
writer this startling eruption
out of the waving laminaria meadows to
him it seemed to occupy a considerable
time
but it is probable that really it was an
affair of a few seconds only
for a time nothing but eyes and then he
speaks of tentacles streaming out
and parting the weed fronds this way and
that
then these things growing larger until
at last the bottom was hidden by their
inter-coiling forms
and the tips of tentacles rose darkly
here and there into the air above the
swell of the waters
one came up boldly to the side of the
boat and clinging to this with three of
its sucker-set tentacles
threw four others over the gunnel as if
with an intention either of over setting
the boat or of clambering into it
mr feisin at once caught up the boat
hook and jabbing furiously at the soft
tentacles forced it to desist
he was struck in the back and almost
pitched overboard by the boatman who was
using his aura to resist a similar
attack on the other side of the boat
but the tentacles on either side at once
relaxed their hold
slid out of sight and splashed into the
water
we better get out of this said mr feison
who was trembling violently
he went to the tiller while the boatmen
and one of the workmen seated themselves
and began rowing
the other workmen stood up in the fore
part of the boat with the boat hook
ready to strike any more tentacles that
might appear
nothing else seems to have been said mr
feison had expressed the common feeling
beyond amendment
in a hushed scared mood with faces white
and drawn
they set about escaping from the
position into which they had so
recklessly blundered
but the oars had scarcely dropped into
the water before dark tapering
serpentine ropes had bound them
and were about the rudder and creeping
up the sides of the boat with a looping
motion
came the suckers again the men gripped
their oars and pulled but it was like
trying to move a boat in a floating raft
of weeds
help here cried the boatmen and mr
feisen and the second workmen rushed to
help lug at the oar
then the man with a boat hook his name
was ewan sprang up with a curse and
began striking downward over the side as
far as he could reach
at the bank of tentacles that now
clustered along the boat's bottom
and at the same time the two rowers
stood up to get a better purchase for
the recovery of their oars
the boatman handed his to mr feissen who
lugged desperately
and meanwhile the boatman opened a big
clasp knife and leaning over the side of
the boat began hacking at the spiring
arms upon the ore shaft
mr feissen staggering with the quivering
rocking of the boat his teeth set
his breath coming short and the veins
starting on his hands as he pulled at
his oar
suddenly cast his eyes seaward and there
not 50 yards off across the long rollers
of the incoming tide
was a large boat standing in towards
them with three women and a little child
in it
a boatman was rowing and a little man in
a pink ribbon straw hat and whites
stood in the stern hailing them for a
moment of course mr feison thought of
help
and then he thought of the child he
abandoned his aura forthwith
threw up his arms in a frantic gesture
and screamed to the party in the boat to
keep away for god's sake
it says much for the modesty and courage
of mr feisen
that he does not seem to be aware that
there was any quality of heroism in his
action at this juncture
the ore he had abandoned was at once
drawn under and presently reappeared
floating about 20 yards away
at the same moment mr feison felt the
boat under him lurch violently
and a horse scream a prolonged cry of
terror from hill the boatman
causing him to forget the party of
excursionists altogether
he turned and saw hill crouching by the
forward roalock
his face convulsed with terror and his
right arm over the side
and drawn tightly down he gave now a
succession of short
sharp cries mr feissen believes that he
must have been hacking at the tentacles
below the water line
and have been grasped by them but of
course it is quite impossible to say now
certainly what had happened
the boat was healing over so that the
gunnel was within 10 inches of the water
and both ewin and the other laborer was
striking down into the water
with oar and boat hook on either side of
hill's arm
mr feison instinctively placed himself
to counter-poise them
then hill who was a burly powerful man
made a strenuous effort and rose almost
to a standing position
he lifted his arm indeed clean out of
the water
hanging to it was a complicated tangle
of brown ropes
and the eyes of one of the brutes that
had hold of him glaring straight and
resolute
showed momentarily above the surface the
boat healed more and more
and the green brown water came pouring
in a cascade over the side
then hill slipped and fell with his ribs
across the side
and his arm and the massive tentacles
about it splashed back into the water
he rolled over his boot kicked mr
feison's knee as that gentleman rushed
forward to seize him
and in another moment fresh tentacles
had whipped about his waist and neck
and after a brief convulsive struggle in
which the boat was nearly capsized
hill was lugged overboard the boat
righted with a violent jerk that all but
sent mr feissen over the other side
and hid the struggle in the water from
his eyes
he stood staggering to recover his
balance for a moment and as he did so he
became aware that the struggle and the
inflowing tide had carried them close
upon the weedy rocks again
not four yards off a table of rocks
still rose in rhythmic movements above
the inwash of the tide
in a moment mr feison seized the ore
from ewin gave one vigorous stroke
then dropping it ran to the boughs and
left he felt his feet slide over the
rock
and by a frantic effort leapt again
towards a further mass he stumbled over
this
came to his knees and rose again
look out cried someone and a large drab
body struck him
he was knocked flat into a tidal pool by
one of the workmen
and as he went down he heard smothered
choking cries that he believed at the
time came from hill
then he found himself marveling at the
shrillness and variety of hill's voice
someone jumped over him and a curving
rush of foamy water poured over him and
passed
he scrambled to his feet dripping and
without looking seaward
ran as fast as his terror would let him
shoreward
before him over the flat space of
scattered rocks stumbled the two workmen
one a dozen yards in front of the other
he
looked over his shoulder at last and
seeing that he was not pursued
faced about he was astonished
from the moment of the rising of the
cephalopods out of the water he had been
acting too swiftly to fully comprehend
his actions
now it seemed to him as if he had
suddenly jumped out of an evil dream
for there was the sky cloudless and
blazing with the afternoon sun
the sea weltering under its pitiless
brightness the soft creamy foam of the
breaking water
and the low long dark ridges of rock the
rated boat floated
rising and falling gently on the swell
about a dozen yards from shore
hill and the monsters all the stress and
tumult of that fierce fight for life
had vanished as though they had never
been
mr feison's heart was beating violently
he was throbbing to the fingertips
and his breath came deep there was
something missing
for some seconds he could not think
clearly enough what this might be
sun sky sea rocks what was it
then he remembered the boatload of
excursionists it had vanished
he wondered whether he had imagined it
he turned and saw the two workmen
standing side by side
under the projecting masses of the tall
pink cliffs
he hesitated whether he should make one
last attempt to save the man hill
his physical excitement seemed to desert
him suddenly and leave him aimless and
helpless
he turned forward stumbling and waiting
towards his two companions
he looked back again and there were now
two boats floating
and the one farthest out at sea pitched
clumsily bottom upward
so it was that hapletus ferox made its
appearance upon the devonshire coast
so far this has been its most serious
aggression
mr fyson's account taken together with
the wave of boating and bathing
casualties to which i have already
eluded
and the absence of fish from the cornish
coasts that year
points clearly to a shoal of these
voracious deep-sea monsters
prowling slowly along the subtidal
coastline
hunger migration has i know been
suggested as the force that drove them
hither
but for my own part i prefer to believe
the alternative theory of hemsley
hemsley holds that a pack or shoal of
these creatures
may have become enamored of human flesh
by the accident of a foundered ship
sinking among them and have wandered in
search of it out of their custom zone
first waylaying and following ships and
so coming to our shores in the wake of
the atlantic traffic
but to discuss hemsley's cogent and
admirably stated arguments would be out
of place
here it would seem that the appetites of
the shoal were satisfied by the catch of
eleven people
four so far as can be ascertained there
were ten people
in the second boat and certainly these
creatures gave no further signs of their
presence off sidmouth that day the coast
between seton and budley salterton was
patrolled all that evening
and night by four preventive service
boats the men in which were armed with
harpoons and cutlasses
and as the evening advanced a number of
more or less similarly equipped
expeditions
organized by private individuals joined
them
mr feissen took no part in any of these
expeditions
about midnight excited hails were heard
from a boat about a couple of miles out
at sea
to the southeast of sidmuth and a
lantern was seen waving in a strange
manner to and fro and up and down
the nearer boats at once hurried towards
the alarm
the venturesome occupants of the boat a
seaman a curate and two schoolboys
had actually seen the monsters passing
under their boat
the creatures it seems like most
deep-sea organisms
were phosphorescent and they had been
floating five fathoms deep or so
like creatures of moonshine through the
blackness of the water
their tentacles retracted and as if
asleep rolling over and over
and moving slowly in a wedge-like
formation towards the southeast
these people told their story in
gesticulated fragments
as first one boat drew alongside and
then another
at last there was a little fleet of
eight or nine boats collected together
and from them a tumult like the chatter
of a marketplace
rose into the stillness of the night
there was little or no disposition to
pursue the shoal
the people had neither weapons nor
experience for such a dubious chase
and presently even with a certain relief
it may be the boats turned shoreward
and now to tell what is perhaps the most
astonishing fact in this whole
astonishing raid
we have not the slightest knowledge of
the subsequent movements of the shoal
although the whole southwest coast was
now alert for it
but it may perhaps be significant that a
cachalot was stranded off sarc on june
the third
two weeks and three days after the
sidmuth affair a living hapletuthis came
ashore on calais sands
it was alive because several witnesses
saw its tentacles moving
in a convulsive way but it is probable
that it was dying
a gentleman named pouche obtained a
rifle and shot it
that was the last appearance of a living
hapletuthis
no others were seen on the french coast
on the 15th of june a dead carcass
almost complete was washed ashore near
torquay
and a few days later a boat from the
marine biological station
engaged in dredging off plymouth picked
up a rotting specimen
slashed deeply with a cutless wound how
the former had come by its death
it is impossible to say and on the last
day of june
mr egbert kane an artist bathing near
newland
threw up his arms shrieked and was drawn
under
a friend bathing with him made no
attempt to save him but swam at once for
the shore
this was the last fact to tell of this
extraordinary raid from the deeper sea
whether it is really the last of these
horrible creatures it is as yet
premature to say
but it is believed and certainly it is
to be hoped that they have returned now
and returned for good to the sunless
depths of the middle seas
out of which they have so strangely and
so mysteriously arisen
you